- Have y'all ever met before?
(audience clapping)
- At a show.
- We did a game show together.
- Yes.
- Good to see you again.
- Yes. Yes.
- What game show?
- What was it?
- "Match Game".
- "Match Game". Yes.
- You both were like...
You were like searching for the game.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Where was it?
Where was it?
- It was one of them.
- Oh, it was.
(Kelly laughs)
- So your mom was musical, right?
- My mom actually moved to
California chasing my father
and she came with a guitar.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So she-
- [Kelly] And a dream-
- And a dream, yeah.
- Okay.
- So yeah, she always wanted to sing.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She made a little 45
when she first got here.
- [Kelly] Aww.
- [Niecy] That was a long time ago.
- [Kelly] Is that her?
- [Niecy] Oh, yeah.
That's my mother singing.
- Oh, my goodness!
Look at this character. I love her.
And I want that hat.
- That's my mother trying
to sing "Old Town Road".
(Kelly claps and laughs)
(audience laughing)
I don't know if the road is old or new,
but I don't wanna be on it.
(audience laughs)
- Wait, what?
Does she sing like that
all the time just randomly?
- Well, you know what ends up happening,
in my house for Mother's Day,
the kids always do a talent show for me,
because I perform for the world.
I'm like, "Y'all get up there
and do something for me".
- Aww...
- Yeah.
And so-
- I love that.
(audience clapping)
- I love that too.
- Yeah, I make them do it.
- Yeah.
- And my mother-
- With a smile, "I make them do it".
- I make them do it.
(all laughing)
And my mother never wants to be left out.
So sometimes she'll get in on the act.
- She's a Grab The Mic mama-
- [Niecy] Very much.
- Yeah. Oh, I love that kind of mom.
- Very much.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Is where the personality came...
Okay. Okay.
(audience laughs)
So your wife, Jessica, she's a singer too?
- [Niecy] Yes.
- [Kelly] So, does she
perform for you as well?
- Does she? Oh!
(all laughing)
Honey.
(Kelly clapping and laughing)
It's hard for me to keep
clothes on in my house, because-
- Oh my God, I love you! (clapping)
(all laughing)
- That voice and that guitar,
it's a whole thing of a thing.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Yeah.
- It's a very sexy thing-
- Yeah, well, you know,
we recently went on vacation together.
We just got back from Bora Bora,
and I know I'm married
to a musician for real,
because the guy is up there performing,
everybody's having drinks,
and the next thing you know,
here she's up there whispering in his ear.
Now, she is taking over his spot,
(audience laughing)
got his guitar,
singing me songs, and-
- Oh my gosh. I love it.
- It was-
- Without alcohol? Just straight up-
- No, I didn't say that.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
(audience clapping)
- I was like, wow, just fresh.
Just ready. I love that.
- Wow.
- I was like, "With a little
tequila I might do that".
- No, no, no.
She also, I mean, it's a good thing,
was with me on "Don't Forget The Lyrics".
She was in the band.
- Oh, yeah?
- That's great.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- I'm serious at work and
my better half is not.
(Kelly laugh)
Well, no.
It's the other way around.
She's serious and I'm not, because-
- [Kelly] Oh.
- While I was up there, I
kept trying to flirt with her
and talk to her while I'm doing my job,
and she was giving me nothing.
(audience laughs)
- Nothing?
She's like, "This is
my professional time".
- This is my professional time.
- (laughing and clapping) I love it.
I love it.
- Yeah.
- Y'all seem fun.
- We are.
- Bora Bora is fun.
Did y'all have a good time?
- We had a good time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh man.
But then, we are never
short of a good time.
- I know, but do you go to those places
and you're like, "These people live here".
- Yeah.
- "And why do I live where I live?"
Like, I was going on vacation
this Summer and travel
and I just look around,
I'm like, "Oh, my God,
y'all live here".
- Yeah.
- "You chose heaven,
(audience laughs)
to live in daily".
- But you know why?
It's because we do this.
That's why we can't live there.
- No, I know.
I know, because you can't do this ever...
So, well, I don't know,
everything's changing.